what up guys goes in here for anime
uproar back outing again with everyone's
favorite seven deadly sins youtube
series topped in fact you didn't know
about blank this time we are covering my
favorite character bond the greedy
masochistic romantic himself if you like
watching seven deadly sins videos on
this channel make sure to smash that
like button to let me know if you have
it be sure to subscribe and this is
crucial
hit that notification bell so you
actually get notified when new seven
deadly sins videos drop if you love bond
like I do you'll love the bond I love
the pain shirt they can get over at
anime up Broadcom link in the
description this is my personal favorite
design both because I love bond and
because I love the message of embracing
pain and adversity rather than shirking
away from it out of fear as they say no
pain no gain
anyways enough of my preaching let's
jump into the video fact number one
first of all let's take a look at our 30
and legend because we know that naka
Basu tsuki was heavily inspired by it
when he came up with the idea for the
seven deadly sins and aside from that
Arthurian legend is just awesome so I
have to talk about it you already know
hopefully that Merlyn and King Arthur
are from Arthurian legend and if you
watch my
esken or and Mellie Otis videos you know
that they were also present in Arthurian
legend the question is was bond present
why yes yes he was bond was a king and
early ally of King Arthur he was also
the father of Sir Lancelot that hyper
romantic knight of the round table who
was Arthur's greatest friend until a
girl complicated batters hmm that sounds
familiar
anyways King bonds wife was Elaine so it
seems like this ridiculously cute couple
was always destined to be a thing King
Bond's weapon of choice was a sword
called great rose while bond sacred
treasure is a holy staff also called
great rose anime bond was already king
of the fairies once but let's see if
he'll hold another king title by the end
of the series as always doctor bouzouki
did a great job of adopting a legendary
figure and making him feel fresh human
and likable he turned a side character
from Arthurian legend into
my favorite characters in anime and for
that I will always be thankful fact
number two next let's talk about bonds
popularity since I'm definitely not the
only one who thinks he's awesome
there were actually two seven deadly
sins popularity polls one was from 2015
if we count the online and postcard
votes Vaughn came in second place with
30 2086 votes in between king and Gotha
if we only count the postcard votes then
bond got second with 259 votes coming in
between Mele Otis and Hawke the second
popularity poll took place in 2019 so
this year
Vaughn ended up getting third place
behind King and Milly Otis but ahead of
the sin of pride s kannur in a series
with so many likable and epic characters
it is truly an accomplishment that bond
managed to rank so high so consistently
fact number three every time bond
becomes depressed he willingly gets
himself arrested after Lane died he
allowed himself to be captured he was
wrongly charged with murdering Elaine
and destroying the fairy Kings forest
all so he could satisfy his own greed
for immortality
obviously this was all wrong bond tried
to save a lane but he didn't defend
himself or try to escape the authorities
attempted to have him executed 33 times
but of course it never worked because of
his immortality later when bond thought
that Mele Otis was dead he again allowed
himself to be captured and even tortured
however when he heard the MELAS was
alive he easily freed himself from the
jail he even used a guard tried to kill
him as a personal shaver he got the
perfect shave by simply dodging
Jericho's attacks truly one of the most
epic and easiest prison breaks I've ever
seen
hopefully bond will live happily ever
after and have no other reasons to give
himself over to the authorities again
back number four for this fact let's
look at some of the interesting trivia
information we are given in the data
book about bonds innermost feelings bond
has no complex but he also has nothing
he likes about himself
the person he most respects is hawk and
the person he does not want to make an
enemy up is Melly
otice a fact that makes his attempt to
kill Mellie Otis in order to bring back
Elaine all the more tragic for favorite
animal bond has two answers he loves
both foxes a nod to his sin and to his
werefox father figures Avago and pigs a
nod to master hawk the most embarrassing
thing in his life was that he felt all
fuzzy when jimagua called him his son
just reading that fact made me feel all
fuzzy not gonna lie what he wants most
right now is skinship with Elaine but he
doesn't seem as obsessed as Mellie
Otis's with Elizabeth while Mellie
Otis's favorite scent is Elizabeth's
body and on top of that Mellie Otis even
answered that Elizabeth is his favorite
animal so even though bond is head over
heels for Elaine Mellie Otis definitely
gets the award for biggest case of one
itis lastly we know that bond knows how
to cook but did you know that his
favorite food is anything except Mellie
Otis is cooking you know that someone's
cooking is bad when your favorite food
is literally anything else fact number
five bond was older than s Kannur since
the beginning of the series even though
he looks younger this is because the 40
year old s Kannur has a biological age
of 40 while bond because he drank the
Fountain of Youth has a biological age
of 23 even though he's 43 by the time
the story starts currently he is
actually over 1,000 years old but I am
NOT going to go into too much detail
since that would involve spoiling the
manga for anime only fans if you do want
to know more about bonds age manga
spoilers and all then check out my every
since true age explaining video while
we're on the subject of bonds age I'll
also mention his birthday which is on
February 14th
aka Valentine's Day making him an
Aquarius interestingly enough there's
some noteworthy overlaps between bond
and his zodiac sign the color for
Aquarius is light blue and silver which
is exactly the color of bonds hair which
looks silver but is actually a pale blue
being an Aquarius born on February 14th
your personality is supposed to be
defined by charm romanticism and
impulsiveness we can definitely say all
this applies to bond he's charming that
self-explanatory he's head over heels in
love with Elaine
and he's so impulsive that he greets his
best friend by sending him flying
through a building and later even tries
to kill him as an Aquarius born on
Valentine's Day there are few things
you're supposed to enjoy more than the
feeling of giving and receiving love
bond love's love so much that he was
ready to kill his best friend at one
point so that he could bring the love of
his life back to life as I said before I
can definitely see where Lancelot gets
his romantic personality from
furthermore the Aquarius likes having
fun with friends helping others fighting
for causes and a good listener bond
loves drinking and having a good time
with the sins he's always helping others
during the series he's constantly
fighting to revive Elaine and/or protect
his friends and one of the things he
liked most about Elaine is that she was
a good listener
on the other hand the Aquarius dislikes
limitations broken promises and being
lonely bond hates himself for not being
strong enough to help those closest to
him he works hard to keep his promise to
revive Elaine and his biggest fear is
the loneliness that would result from an
eternal life without Elaine so yeah I'd
say naka Basuki definitely picked the
perfect birthday for our boy bond fact
number 6 let's talk about bonds height
which fascinates me
first off I'll mention that his weight
is 70 kilograms or 154 pounds that's my
weight I am 6 foot 2 inches tall and
people like my brother Anna Mac always
say I'm too skinny even though I'm a fan
of my body type bond also happens to be
Animax favorite character in the seven
deadly sins so as you can imagine I was
extremely excited to learn that bond is
210 centimeters or 6 foot 11 inches tall
meaning that bond one of my favorite
characters is significantly skinnier
than even I am so take that Animax
bond is the tallest of the sins if we
don't count the ants giant form or eScan
ors day time form but let's say it's
nighttime and Deanna's and our human
size form then bond would be the tallest
of all the sins he's definitely a tall
dude especially if you think about the
fact that Goku probably the most famous
anime character ever is only like 5 foot
9 inches tall bond has more than a foot
on this
anime Superman fact number seven for
this fact let's look at the information
we got in the bond and Elayne character
guidebook where some interesting
information was revealed about bond and
Alain's relationship bond wants to have
two children with elaine suggesting that
fairies can have kids with humans even
though they're born from flowers and
trees a bond met Elaine when he was 23
years old and she was his first and only
love if you didn't think bond was a
romantic before you definitely will when
you hear that bond considers Elaine to
be his light for Elaine when she hugs
bond he feels like a big burly tree
which makes sense since bond is like two
whole feet taller than her bond loves
every part of Elaine and we are told the
relationship would not change if Elaine
were to become more busty since fairies
can transform their physical appearance
this may well have happened behind
closed doors back number eight in the
original Japanese bond is voiced by the
35 year old tatsuhisa suzuki suzuki is
the perfect choice since he is the
vocalist in a tokyo rock band and that
just makes sense for bond who's always
had that rock star energy his hobbies
include bicycling karaoke reading and I
always give extra points for reading and
games
Suzuki has voice acted in many other
anime including some of my personal
favorites like attack on Titan and
cuticles basketball fact number nine in
the English dub the bond is voiced by a
36 year old award-winning voice actor
Benjamin disken he played psy in naruto
shippuden joseph joestar in jojo's
bizarre adventure and even venom in the
2017 Spiderman animated series aside
from these roles Benjamin has a long
track record of anime and Western
cartoon performances he even appeared in
Disney's recess which was especially
exciting for me to see
hashtag tender in an interview Benjamin
actually answers some questions about
bond he said that he admires bonds
ability to remain cool under pressure
when asked how he would use snatch if he
had the ability
Benjamin responded that he would snatch
Superman's strength and ruled the
universe clearly Benjamin is a very
ambitious voice actor fact number 10
as usual we will do a lightning round of
sorts in lieu of just one fact that
means I will be mentioning as many facts
as I can about bond in a relatively
short period of time
cue the countdown in three two one let's
jam bonds charm point is his fangs
according to the mangaka bond always
reeks of alcohol but he probably doesn't
care since this is favorite scent
he is a considerably good cook and he is
self-taught over the course of a story
he has had a ridiculous amount of
aliases including bandit bond on dead
bond bond with two A's my personal
favorite Fox's sin of greed Lord bond
fairy king bond and the man of greed his
blood type is B and his daily hobby
includes drinking until he passes out
class II during part of the series bond
shared a room with King that must have
been awkward when Elaine came over to
spend the night and finally you may well
have noticed that bond often has a music
symbol inside his speech bubble when
he's talking in the manga this is
because he has the habit of prolonged
the pronunciation of his sentences in a
singing like manner I always wondered
about this music symbol so I'm glad I
finally figured this out during my
research anyways that's it for this
video thank you so much for watching if
you enjoyed it make sure to smash that
like button to let me know if you
haven't be sure to subscribe and this is
absolutely crucial hit that notification
bell so you actually get notified when
new 7 Deadly Sins videos come out a
bunch of you asked for the 10 facts
about bond in the comments section of
the 10 facts about meliodas video so
this video was a no brainer do the same
thing here and give me suggestions for
the next character you want me to cover
in the comments if you want to look epic
and support this channel at the same
time check out our seventh at least
inspired merch like bond love the pain
and esken or praise the sun at anime up
for calm link in the description a big
thank you goes out to our patrons over
on patreon who helped make videos like
this one possible I especially want to
thank our procureur to your patrons the
one and only Gilgamesh nothing but a fan
Jason Wilson King's eldest and angel
Cruz and are the one tier patrons the
ones who stand atop all clans baby ray a
seventeen FF DP Steven Ingrid ah allo
long autumn
Maddi Mac 239 makoto-kun and pylon and
the patrons who transcend greatness
itself Regan Harrison and Lord naksan or
the chosen few who have been
acknowledged by Lord we go himself I'm
super jealous if you enjoy our work you
can support more of it by going over to
patreon calm an Amanda coming a patron
today for as little as one dollar if you
do so you'll get your name featured in
future videos alongside these epic
people right here and you'll even get
access to our private patron only
discord
so check out patreon.com/lenguin
anyways thanks again for all of your
support remember to love the pain and
until next time see us space Cowboys
[Music]